merci madame la présidente monsieur le
garde des sceaux l'augmentation de la
part des mineurs de plus en plus jeunes
dans la délinquance notamment par des
faits de violence physique et dans la
criminalité est aujourd'hui un constat
que l'on ne peut plus ignorer le drame
que constitue le décès de cette
adolescent de 16 ans poignardé au thorax
ainsi que la grave blessure de son
camarade aux abords de leur lycée à
Thiais dans le Val-de-Marne ne doit plus
se reproduire nous pensons à cet instant
à la douleur de leur famille
d'après les premières précisions du
procureur il s'agit d'un conflit de
bande c'est fait d'une violence extrême
se multiplie dans notre société prouvant
la capacité des pouvoirs publics
endiguer ce phénomène ces jeunes en
perte de repères et d'autorité ne
répondent plus qu'à leur loi à la loi de
leur bande ou de leur clan se moquant
des conséquences de leurs actes nous
sommes bien aujourd'hui au delà de ce
qui relève de l'émotion suscité par de
telles comportements mais bien un
véritable défi sociétal et
civilisationnel celui de l'autorité pour
que chacun puisse vivre librement dans
une société plus sûre et celui de la
responsabilité pour que la culture de
l'excuse ne soit plus la règle si la
prévention est nécessaire elle doit être
couplée à la répression en accord avec
les réflexions et les propositions
formulées par le président de l'AMF
David Lisnard qui dresse avec les mers
le constat de l'augmentation de ses
faits de délinquance dans leur commune
j'ai rédigé une proposition de loi
prévoyant la levée de l'application des
règles d'atténuation des peines dès
l'âge de 13 ans pour les faits les plus
graves l'abaissement de l'excuse de
minorité à 20% de la peine encourue et
l'instauration d'une nouvelle infraction
autonome de salimputable mineur qui
engagerait la responsabilité des parents
en effet
face à un sentiment d'impunité il est
urgent de rétablir l'autorité de l'État
l'autorité de la police l'autorité de la
justice de l'école et des parents je
vous remercie monsieur le ministre ne
croyez-vous pas qu'il est indispensable
d'adapter le code pénal des mineurs à la
réalité à la réalité de ce fléau
grandissant merci